por primera vez periodistas
independientes han podido informar desde
dentro de la zona de conflicto han tigre
los reporteros de la agencia afp
entraron enumera una de las primeras
ciudades objetivos del ejército etíope a
principios de este mes en esta ciudad de
30.000 habitantes las casas están
salpicadas de agujeros de bala muchos
residentes han resultado heridos
y hagan un contrato no esperábamos un
bombardeo de repente empezamos a oír
armas de guerra y explosiones y luego la
gente entró en pánico no podía salir de
una casa estaba aterrorizado
los residentes de general lamentaban que
las tensiones entre el gobierno y el
partido regional del frente de
liberación popular de tigre se
convirtieran en una guerra que según se
reporta está dejando cientos de muertos
en todo el país
fabra show en esta ciudad estaba al
borde del desarrollo pero ahora hemos
vuelto a vivir muy apretados debido a
una guerra innecesaria
a los analistas les preocupa que el
gobierno central esté trayendo
rápidamente administradores de la vecina
región a majara durante décadas ha
habido disputas por la tierra entre ti y
greenes y amarás y se teme que este
cambio puede inflamar las tensiones
étnicas